when you said you've walked out of
particular workplaces and felt low
self-worth I think that's really
interesting because I think that if you
say in that moment and it prevents your
whole day from being creative and then
how do you shake that off is what do you
do so that you can go back to write
another one flower cool or a script or
good question letting it follow you
discipline has always been one of my
strengths um that's rock bottom and
that's the opposite side of my
discipline is the fact that I need to
learn to relax but I am very very good
at drawing the line and saying now you
will Ex the flip side of it and the
thing that I think is the healthier
place for me to go to is the fact that I
am building a community with my
performers with my with my you know my
production people and my audience and
you guys are part of that community you
know and I owe that community everything
and I always will that's the nature of
the work that we do that's the beauty of
it that's where the sharing comes in you
know there are lots of people out there
that think that it's silly to tell
stories and it's frivolous but there are
a lot of people out there who feel it's
very very important and I think those
people shape the lives of the ones even
who don't want to pay attention and
ultimately um that's uh its duty but
it's also um it's a gift and it's it's a
sacred duty and um it's not something I
could ever turn my back on no matter how
I'm feeling the show must go on so you
tell yourself that or you remind
yourself of that when it's probably easy
to wallow in self-pity and I'm only I
don't have Joe anymore it's just it's
it's on my mind all the time like you
know what I mean that's that's that's
the commitment that I have made and I
made that commitment years ago I've been
living that commitment for 10 years at
least and I'm at a point now where my my
actors and my production p
all and my audience are every bit as
much my family as my mom and my sister
and my dad I carry them with me
everywhere I go and part of the reason
why I don't like working in jobs that I
don't respect is because I feel like I'm
not honoring them to the degree that I
could and when i walk out there with me
and it's time for me to do what i can to
make life better for everybody you know
that's that's now you know at the
beginning it was a question of
discipline you've got to get it done or
it's never gonna be done you're never
gonna know what it is unless you finish
it but i think that's like stage one you
don't you mean that's i'm now in stage
two where it's like wow like there they
are what are you gonna do like if
there's if there's an audience and
there's a stage and no one's on stage
you best get out there I don't care what
you do tap dance tell a story find
something right away make it quick cuz
the lights are up you know i mean that's
that's that the you know people people
who come from film school people who
come from other parts of the
entertainment industry people who have
not performed on stage do not understand
that the show must go on is not even a
mantra its nature it has to like it's
it's own thing the show is alive and
you're either gonna be a part of that
and you're either gonna fuel it and feed
it and give or you're not and if you're
not what are you doing go find go be an
accountant get out